hey everyone so a bunch of people wrote
in some questions and i thought i'd take
a little time to answer them
so we'll just jump right in uh sathwick
asks
does finding your why mean you'll always
stay motivated
the simple answer is no um stan
finding your way does not mean you
always stay motivated it does mean you
always stay inspired
our motivation can come and go bad
nights sleep you can be
unmotivated a hard day at work something
goes wrong
motivation waxes and wanes and that's
why the why matters so much
is because something that's so unstable
we want something that has some
solidity something foundational a why
means
uh we always stay inspired because we
always have a sense of where we come
from
despite the daily comings and goings of
our motivation
next question oliver asks what are the
most important
soft skills and how can we develop them
okay first of all i
hate the term soft skills we talk about
hard skills and soft skills
as if they're in opposition those things
are opposites
i like the term hard skills and human
skills hard skills the skills we need to
do our job
and human skills are the skills we need
to be better versions of ourselves and
we need both
so i'm going to re-restate your question
oliver what are the most important human
skills we need
and how can we develop them listening is
the big one i think
it's one of the skills that is
desperately lacking in our world and
definitely in our places of work today
and even in our relationships
so i think we can all learn to be better
listeners which also leads to all the
other things
having difficult conversations how to do
those empathy
how to uh how to give and receive
feedback have an effective
confrontation these are all necessary
skills we need
i think listening and empathy are the
too big that underlie
okay next um
card's upside down now uh steve asks
what's the
greatest challenge we face regarding
mental health
in the workplace such a great question
the fact that we even talking about
mental health in the workplace i think
the biggest challenge we face
is that companies recognize that mental
health in the workplace
is a thing and again it's about empathy
it's about seeing human beings as human
beings
about seeing employees as people not
just
uh functionaries an understanding that
people have good days and bad days
that people have stresses at home that
affect how they
feel and someone's mental health really
matters it matters
how they show up to do their work it
also really matters how they show up
as a team member so i think the biggest
challenge we face regarding mental
health in the workplace is just
recognizing that it's a thing
that companies have some responsibility
to uh
take care of the mental health of their
people okay
uh adichia asks how can we play
education as an infinite game
great question i think we have to accept
that education is an infinite game
school is finite and the rules of school
are operate
by the finite rules we have grades
they're an agreed-upon metric
we have an agreed-upon objective we have
to get there by the end of the year
but even in school even though sometimes
it is competitive
the goal is how we can learn more and to
show up with an infinite mindset i'm
going to school not just to get the
to become first i'm going to school just
so i can go on to get the
best job or whatever it is which is very
uh
very egocentric but rather i'm coming to
school to learn
i'm coming to school to teach i'm coming
to school to enrich
i mean all of these ideas that there's
more to school than simply
uh objectives
finite objectives i think is really
important and i think educators and
school systems need to start asking
themselves
are we preparing our students to play in
the infinite game
are we just driving them to get the best
grades they can get into the best
college or get the best job
okay next uh howard asks
um how can we best deal with big egos in
the workplace
or elsewhere well
big egos aren't the problem unhealthy
egos are the problem
i hope you have a big ego there's a big
difference between
uh being self-confident and being
conceited
being self-confident means you think
you're good
being conceited means you think you're
better than other people i hope you have
big egos our
our goal is to help people build their
confidence so that they see themselves
as good but we never want people to
think themselves as better as others
so if we are working with people who
think they are better than us
uh that's the question so number one is
uh
uh sometimes uh big egos and healthy
egos
are masquerading as uh masquerade
in place of um insecurity so
sometimes attacking them and thinking
that their egos are outsized
maybe they are just insecure and they're
compensating for something
maybe they're uncertain or unsure so
strangely enough a little empathy
matters
but if somebody truly does have an
outsized ego the way i think they're
better than everyone else
just enjoy it smile go about your job
don't worry about it
as long as they're not because taking
them on is only going to
create things and make things worse i
throughout my career i've worked with
people who like to
posture and prove and i just sort of
smile and let them have their way
kill them with kindness you know don't
let it get to me
uh because if it gets to me i become
competitive with them and i just sort of
focus on the work that i'm doing
um hopefully that helps a little bit
okay these are all over the place um so
let's try another one here emma
asks um how can we learn to be
more decisive
it's about taking a risk right making a
decision now
with anything that we're learning um you
can practice small
you don't have to start practicing being
decisive with big things
you can start practicing to being
decisive with small things
what do you want for dinner tonight some
people like oh i don't know whatever
it's all fine
try just making a decision i'm gonna
have chicken tonight that's what i'm
gonna have for dinner today
um uh i'd say you know do you want to
eat in order to eat out of what
restaurant but
we don't do that right now um uh but
start with little decisions you know
what movie do you want to watch i can
sit in front
and flip through the channels at all the
previews i can sit for the
length of a movie trying to decide what
movie i want to watch and then it's too
late
and i don't end up watching a movie pick
one just
pick one and i think if you can practice
making lots and lots of little decisions
you'll build the muscle and slowly
you'll start making bigger decisions
start small okay narjes asks
um how can we break a procrastination
habit
oh my god i wish i knew uh i've been
putting that one off for a long time
um actually one thing that does work for
me is i'm good at working with people
so i can procrastinate working out for
example i'll do it tomorrow i'll do it
tomorrow i'll do it tomorrow
and then before you know it two weeks
have passed um but if i have a buddy
to work out with even over facetime i'm
more likely to show up so for me
some people who are more disciplined and
more organized having
a plan and writing things down and
keeping track of things so there's a
metric
that works for a lot of people so every
day you write down the thing you want to
do and so you like you don't want to
break the habit
um people like me who that's good for
like two weeks and then i fall off the
bandwagon
um having an accountability partner
where i actually enjoy doing
something with someone even if it's work
just having uh if i have to do some work
uh that that i keep procrastinating i'll
call someone up and say can we just work
together we'll turn on
facetime and we'll just do our separate
work that that helps a lot
um hope that helps uh try it tomorrow
uh nina asks uh what do you do
if you're too far in your career to make
a pivot
but aren't feeling fulfilled ah so the
question is
are you ever too far in your career to
make a pivot
um sometimes we have golden handcuffs
that's true where we're in a position
where things are good and we don't want
to let go and throw it away
um there are ways to pivot inside our
careers
but when you say make a pivot i mean if
you're not enjoying yourself
and it's just the stability or or the or
the
um the salary that's making you uh
not want to make a change if you have a
partner talk to your partner
because it's going to be something that
you can you have to make that decision
together
if you don't have a partner that you
that you're you're with um talk to your
friends and family
you will find that you will have more
courage to make a difficult decision
like this
if you have at least one person who
believes in you and loves you and says
you got this even if it doesn't work out
i'll still be
there with you we'll figure this out
together how can we do this in a way
that um we can make you happy uh try
try talking with somebody about it if
you aren't feeling fulfilled
and by the way if you're not feeling
fulfilled it's not necessarily you have
to abandon your career sometimes you can
find a new job within the company you're
in
you talk to if you have a good
relationship with your leader sit down
and say i think i'm curious about other
things
um uh and start poking around outside so
yeah
your happiness is way more important uh
what else we got here
uh charlene asks how do i manage the
expectations of others
not setting them too high or too low
ah i struggle with this i try and say
yes to everybody
and what i've learned is saying no has
been one of the most valuable skills
i've learned i'm still not great at it
because what i learned is when i try and
say yes to everybody i end up
disappointing multiple
people and so learning to say no
saying you know and saying ah i so want
to do that
unfortunately my schedule this week is
insane
and i just can't get to it this week um
you know the old adage is also um keep
expectations low and then over deliver
um that's also really fun to do um
obviously
uh it's fun to set high expectations but
if you want to manage expectations
either be realistic or or or under
promise here's one little trick that i
learned
somebody said when can you have that
done by and the mistake i used to make i
used to say
tuesday now i say next week
right and then hopefully i'll get them
to tuesday and they're really excited
but if i get it to them on friday
it's fine um what time do you want to
meet uh
three o'clock or this afternoon
and that way i can better manage my work
if i'm
bad at managing my workload or things
are taking longer than i expect
i leave the a little broader uh
boundaries on
the sandbox that has helped me a great
deal i hope that helps you too
charlene okay last question from anna
uh how can we balance and lost my
balance that was really funny i actually
lost my balance
when i read the word balance okay how
can we balance
full-time work with creative projects
creatively uh so um separation of church
and state i'm a great believer in it
um work is for work and home is for home
um and sometimes they blend sometimes we
have to bring work home
um but i'm a great believer what's
helped me believe it or not is
scheduling time
so i'll actually schedule time for
creative exercises
um so in my schedule it'll i'll have a
block off
that's for me to do creative things and
that way when i'm building my schedule
or when things are coming in somebody
says can you meet at four o'clock on
thursday i say
sorry i have something else then what i
have then
is to do something creative to do a
creative exercise
so i found that to be really helpful um
also that way i'm not left to the end of
the day to do my creative things every
day
when i may be too tired to do anything
so sometimes i block off time or even
take a day off
simply to do something creative i hope
that helps
thanks for the questions please write in
more i love getting these and i love
sharing
take care of yourself take care of each
other
[Music]